As cancer cells die off, how does our body get rid of them? How are they expelled?
So cancer, when cancer cells die, they die through a process of apoptosis. So apoptosis is normal
program cell death. I have several blog posts about this. I think I call them apoptosis. One of
the apoptosis two or one with some videos about it. So cancer cells can also die through
abnormal ways, pathological cell death. Typically, that's how cancer cells die when you
are exposed to chemotherapy. So chemotherapy is an oxidized agent. It's a poison. And anytime a
cell is poisoned, it dies through a pathological death, through a cell lysis. So the cell
lysis means it breaks apart at first through an oxidative process. That's the danger of
oxidizing agents that you're exposed to chemicals and additives,
color and flavor. It's all these chemicals that are diet. They can they act as oxidizing agents,
they act as poisons and they cause cell lysis. So if you drink a poison, how does somebody die?
If they drink poison, you've seen it in spy movies, they drink a poison and they keel over their dead.
Well, if you drink a oxidizing agent that's a very, very strong oxidizing agent because it's
immediate cell death, immediate cell lysis, and you could you could die quite rapidly.
Well, that's what chemotherapy does. It causes cell lysis. Of course, it's an immediate cell death.
It's going into the bloodstream and you're hoping that it's taken up by cells that are more
metabolically active, a cancer cells. And it is. It is taken up by cells that are more metabolically
active. That's how chemotherapy works. Unfortunately, your hair follicles are more metabolically active.
And your immune system cells are more metabolically active. So you will damage your immune system,
that's why they need to check it. Every time you go in for chemotherapy, visit they need to do a CBC,
see what your white blood cell count is before they can administer the chemotherapy because if it's
too low, another dose of chemotherapy could kill the patient. So I'm going to make sure that your
immune system has recovered enough since the last infusion in order to give you another infusion
of a poison. So it makes it sound like it's a horrible thing, which it is in a way, but
cancer cells will uptake that poison. More readily than a healthy cell will, therefore will kill cancer
cells, bigger than it will kill the healthy cell. Though, but lingers in the body, your will kill healthy
cells as well. It does cause apoptosis sometimes, but more commonly it causes cell lysis within
the pathological cell death. It's a process of the cell, and that's a breaking apart of the cell.
So in the case of cell lysis, the cell just explodes. It breaks apart. And all this cell
exudate is all over the place. So that is, those are called endotoxins, endomines within
toxins, not something from outside of the body. It's toxins from inside of the body, aka the cell
components that have just exploded all over the extracellular space. And now the immune system
has to deal with it. It can fire an immune response, which is going to be just an inflammatory type
response, be a histamine response, other chemo-kind responses, which could actually cause more problems,
more inflammatory cytokines to the area, not necessarily T cells that are going to kill cancer cells,
but more inflammation and fluid that is going to actually hinder a T cell response to be able to
kill cancer cells. It's a negative side of chemotherapy. So then that has to be carried
into the lymph system and then through the bloodstream and basically detoxified. So that's
supposed to detoxification pathways. By the way, a cell dies doing natural methods, or using
the right machine or using herbal therapies. Those are stimulated immune response to kill a cell
through what's called a normal program cell that's or apoptosis. And apoptosis is not a shattering
of the cell. It's not a lysis of the cell. It's a it's a recycling of the cell material.
Goes through a whole process of what's called blebs. It's basically enfolding upon itself. It's
basically the cell is enfolding. It just kind of break into pieces and then your body recycles that
and reuses that. Therefore, when you do you know, right therapy or natural type therapies that
are not oxidative therapies, now there are some natural therapies that are oxidative. But if you do
natural type therapies that are not oxidative, they're immune stimulant type therapies. You know, get
the work cyber type reactions. Technically, one of the ill feelings post chemotherapy is a work
cyber reaction. The work cyber reaction is defined by what you have produced that excess amount of
endotoxins that overwhelm your body and make you feel quite ill. You can feel a lot of malaise,
a lot of fatigue. You just feel ill. You're overwhelming your liver detox pathways. So you are
becoming toxic. So, you know, chemotherapy makes you toxic because of the drug itself. But it's making
you toxic because of the endotoxins that it's producing through cell lysis of both cancer cells and
healthy cells. So, how are cancer cells expelled? It depends on how they do. Hope that explained that.
More details you can look up a poptosis on our blog.